in terms of uh the mining story that you
did you really were focused on kind of
china
and the hash rate shifting out of china
so you walk through like kind of what
were some of the takeaways for you in
that topic
so i was kind of informally talking to a
lot of people when i was in miami the
first time around and every single
person kept bringing
up this like drain of 50 to 60 percent
of the hash rate out of china
and how people weren't talking enough
about it
and so then i just started to get in the
weeds of it uh and and having lived in i
lived in hong kong for three years with
cnn uh
spent you know a lot of time going back
and forth between uh beijing and hong
kong
and so i was personally interested uh
for for different reasons and
there i mean there are so many angles
here like yes the destination side of it
like where are they going to go
um and and that's important to me not
just from
the standpoint of what does this mean
for the us and
our mining infrastructure will become
more progressive in those policies will
we move faster
to build um you know the systems
necessary to host those miners
but it's also very interesting to me in
terms of like the climate debate around
bitcoin
and it's something where i've been i've
been wanting to do a piece for a while
on this and i think the new cambridge
data comes out next month and so i
cannot wait to sink my teeth into
that but where they go will really
decide
the direction this argument takes you
know um and and it's a toss-up right
because like
miners leaving china is not a great
thing necessarily like there's tons of
hydropower in addition to
tons of like coal mines right and so
i mean i don't know if it's a full net
net but like a full wash um
when you have them all exit but where
they go will decide what people say
about bitcoin's carbon footprint for the
next decade
i think yeah and i think part of what's
so fascinating about china is so there's
certain
uh chinese provinces where it's almost
100 hydro
right and it's like actually that should
be the lighthouse on the
uh kind of uh hill if you will in terms
of what we want people to do to be 100
renewable
um at the same time there's a lot of
examples where that's not what we want
people to do and it's the coal
but the u.s i think on a net basis
you know kind of side by side of china
is a more green grid but to your point
you could just go do a coal mine in the
united states and that's not much better
right and it's actually a negative if
you went from renewable in china and to
uh
non-renewable in the united states so
there's nuance here not just
oh switched countries and it solves all
the problems yeah and then kazakhstan
like it's a next-door neighbor to china
ate a cool climate uh they're very lacks
on their building policies
and it's coal powered so i mean i'm
i mean i'm fascinated to see where they
go i think for the time being i was
talking to nick carter about this too
that
the the hash rate probably go offline
there right and so the miners who are
still mining are going to be a little
bit richer
um and we might see special like
zones set up to absorb these miners but
yeah one i think also in the united
states what's really fascinating
is uh you're getting some migration just
in general
uh but it seems like the us is much more
innovative in finding uh various energy
sources so yeah you know
oil and gas and kind of flare gas
capture yeah
there's great american mining a couple
other companies that are doing it they
seem to be really a us-based strategy
uh before it went anywhere else but you
could see very quickly like hey where
else do they have
oil like well this could be it you know
done in many many different
uh regions very quickly and so in some
way it feels like china
served as a kind of a breeding gown
and was a very big part of the mining
hash rate for a while
that's now shifted and is changing
rapidly